history has shown that there are only
two things a society needs in order to
be
successful the first is the ability to
provide a good education to most people
that teaches them skills and civility so
they can be productive in other words
the development of human capital from
the
start this teaching typically comes from
parents and teachers who in still good
values and principles to be productive
with
others the second is an environment that
gives people the resources that they can
be productive at its best that
environment provides Financial Capital
that comes from investors Banks and
capital markets to invest in those who
are capable of being
productive this environment must be a
civil place to live work and raise one's
families ideally one in which there are
many exciting people doing many exciting
things so that it is a creatively
stimulating environment in other words
having the right people in the right
environment that supports productive
creativity throughout the life cycle is
what it takes